today's episode is brought to you by
magic mind
flow state now comes in a bottle
magic mind it's the anti-procrastination
organic alternative to five hour energy
you're going to love it go to
magicmind.co use promo code
theo to get 10 off today's guest
is environmental attorney author
and president of the children's health
defense
to name a few things he's outspoken
he's i mean he just knows so much he's
like
i mean he's just like wandering through
a library
uh it is my friend mr robert kennedy jr
[Music]
[Applause]
me
we didn't have like violence we had a
lot of cranes you know i actually
thought about you a couple weeks ago i
was down in
it was my first time going to um
this place called yoskolovsky it's down
like
like the fishing villages off of like
new orleans it's probably about 30
minutes away
and they pronounce it a little bit
different because i think it's like
super polish the word or something
it starts with like a couple of
different y's and so it's like it's kind
of hard to pronounce but i got down
there and i saw egrets i saw cranes
um i saw a couple owls
you know and i actually thought about
you because i know that you care about
the animals so much and stuff like that
well i've spent a lot of time and yeah
which is oh yeah near where you are
between baton rouge and
uh and new orleans and that's one of the
biggest um
staging zones for the migrations of
you know the waterfowl and um
you know a lot of the other migratory
birds that are about to go down to latin
america i think it's actually the
biggest
uh wetland in north america it's bigger
than bigger than the everglades but
we started talking you and i started
talking about this because i did time
mike tyson's
yeah hot boxing hot boxing and um
you were asking me how it was and i
he's very subdued um
you know i i really i love him he's very
very subdued
um but we ended up talking a lot about
pigeons
because he was a pigeon guy that's how
he kind of started he got a fight he got
in the fight
over somebody who stole his [ __ ] and
this first time he ever hit anybody oh
damn
and that's kind of a famous story but
he's a pigeon fancier and
i grew up with pigeons i started racing
homing pigeons when i was seven years
old
so was that big because i remember i
went to the spy museum one time in
philadelphia
and they had pigeons that had like a
little briefcase on their arm you know
they had pigeon they'll have like a
little
can you bring that up to nick they'll
have pigeons that even have like a
little backpack on you know and they
used to use them for spy work
yeah they have yes absolutely and in
fact
they used them for well of course they
they've always been
a military asset because they would use
them to communicate you know before they
had telephones and walkie-talkies and in
fact
they used them right up into until world
war
um world war one
and and they really used them like if
you do like what can you tell the pigeon
and he'll go
you can't tell him anything but you can
the pigeon will
always go back to the first place that
he saw a daylight
oh if you if you you know raise a pity
you get if you get an adult pigeon you
buy a bit in a pigeon auction
and a you know a really big homer
classic these days
people pay a million dollars for uh a
good homer
for a good homer pigeon please they rate
them by miles oh if you're a thousand
mile
bird you know you you're worth a lot of
money
back when i was a kid we would you know
yeah those are called blue bars okay
and those are uh hungarians
which is the kind that i used to raise
and we would put him in a a train and
the train with all the
other you know we were a pigeon club and
all the other people would put him in a
train
right outside of my home in virginia and
the train would go down to delaware
and the conductor would then release
them all at once and when your pigeon
came back to your coop you would
you would take his band off and run down
to the post office and have it time
stamped and that's how they would
you know that's how they really races
yeah and so so the pigeon they'll know
so so so the first place that sees
daylight is the place it'll always come
back to that'll always come back
so if you buy a pigeon at an auction or
whatever
you have to keep that pigeon locked up
for the rest of his life because
if he ever gets out he'll go back to the
place where he was born
and the military like a hot woman kind
of
you know the military they taught them
how to go
to a they would have a little a coupon
wheels
and they would teach them to go to that
coop and they would keep moving the coop
so that the pigeon would learn to
find the coupe going back to a
you know to a stationary barn wow
and um in fact during world war one
the uh they knew where all of the falcon
falcons which i moved to falconry when i
was about 10 years old
is that early to be moving to that or is
that where you like where is it that's
when i found out about it and there
there happened to be a guy who lived um
near me who was one of the pioneers of
american falconry
i read a book about it my uncle was in
the white house and
and i and people were talking about
camelot and i read a book about camelot
by t.h white who is a british author who
is also a falconer and
he has and that that book was called the
once and future king
he later made it into a disney you know
movie
called the sword in the stone oh wow but
there's a chapter in there
on falconry and i read that chapter and
i just said this what i want to do with
my life
and as it happened there was a guy who
had been an
all-american football player at uh at
penn state
he lived about a mile from my house his
name was alvin i
and he was one of the pioneers of
american falconry and my father knew
about him because
whenever he worked as a um as a designer
of jets
at the pentagon of jets yeah
he was designing jets and he was an
engineer
and one of the things that um
the state department knew about him
because whenever they were visiting
arab dignitaries who came to washington
the arabs are all crazy about falconry
really that's
crazy about it and that's falcons right
yeah that's falcons so falcon is i mean
so when you moved up to falcons were you
just i mean i can imagine if you leaving
pigeon you probably left them behind huh
well actually pigeons remain are
kind of part of the sport of falconry
okay
you use pigeons and all in different
parts of the sport
so i kept pigeons i had pigeons all in
my life until really until i moved to
california six years ago i kept pigeons
um but i i still have hawks
at you know back in new york i have my
falconry license
out here but i never brought them out
here i got involved in surfing and you
know a lot of other stuff and it just
wasn't as easy here
um but uh um
yeah so like so this guy i apprenticed
under this guy under alvin i
i'm beginning when i was about 11 years
old
and then at that time there was no
regulation they passed regulations
in 1973 and then you had to get a
license
and you know i was i actually wrote the
test
at falconer's take um in new york state
and
elsewhere to get their license and i've
been involved in it my whole life
so would you compete like once you have
this knowledge in this so you're
you're learning like what is the man
teaching you when you learn from the
from uh
mister what is his name he's teaching
you how to
how to drop the hawk how to care for
it how to treat it when it gets sick and
of course how to train it and then hunt
with it
you're hunting my birds take
um i flying mainly harry sox
and i've flown every kind of hawk but
nowadays i fly mainly harris hogs are
very easy and very very fun and they
they hunt in groups they're very
sociable they seem to be
you know what you and i would interpret
as affectionate towards humans and
they're almost like dogs so when you
take them to hunt well yeah this is
because i mean i grew up raising hands i
didn't mean to be talking about this
no it's fascinating man because so let's
see a harris hall
um i just want to see what this even
looks like
and now when you take them to train or
something what do they do
they well when you take them to hunt
with them like okay
you you they're in a cage or on your arm
no
actually they'll ride on the back seat
of the car unbelievable
and then and i knew yeah and then you
knew that i mean i just had an inkling
if i look like that man i'm definitely
you know i'm not driving i'm definitely
getting a ride
and they uh they're really just like
dogs when you get to the place
where you're hunting you let them out of
the car and they'll usually
jump up and and sit for a second in
orient on the roof of the car and then
when you
as you start walking through the woods
they'll follow you
they yeah and then i use i hunt with
dogs too
i have a couple of dogs who will be
you know looking for rabbits and
squirrel and pheasant and turkey
and when they um and when something
moves they'll chase it
okay so if you see when you're walking
through the woods they'll what just be
kind of going from tree to tree they
know that you're their owner
they've got to treat a tree they stay in
the canopy above your head
and they know that you're gonna kick up
game
so um you know they you know they learn
and they learn
like i the bird that i was flying until
recently i had for 24 years
and then every year i would breed that
bird and get
some eggs and babies out of them and you
know those birds are now all over
new york state and all over the um at
least all over the east coast
you're working at the grassroots level
of helping the environment if you are
breeding birds
i like i said i you know it was a
passion for me from when i was
when i was really little
man yeah because we i grew up i used to
sell hamsters when i was growing up and
we used to
you know the big ones around us were the
roborovski hamsters we bring that up
nick
um this is in louisiana yeah
and we used to sell hamsters and guinea
pigs or jeep pigs they used to
they eat those down there yeah they call
them cooys
and uh in latin america and ecuador oh
you get down to oh you get down to
ecuador bro you take a jer you take a
gerbil anywhere south of uh
paraguay and it's a wrap you know i mean
nicaragua you show up with one of these
bad boys they think it's thanksgiving
you know um but we have a different
affinity for animals now i feel like if
it looks cute or if it's been marketed
as cute
it becomes not a food anymore you know
um once things get marketed as being too
cute so you'll get there into the truth
it's not a good food
in my opinion anyhow
yeah and i you know when i when i i
spent a lot of time in ecuador and i
lived in peru for a while and i ended up
eating a lot of guinea pigs
i went to a restaurant i took cheryl to
a restaurant where they were selling
them for food and they had them
you know how the um when you go into a
seafood restaurant in new england and
they have all the lobsters in the tank
and you can pick the one and they're
alive in there well they had one of
those with it they had this
really cute guinea pig house
and you could pick the guinea pig you
were eating and you know
cheryl is just broke her heart yeah i
broke her heart
hopefully it wasn't balanced that wasn't
balanced
well so so very similar to the lobster
in the tank they just had these guinea
pigs just like in a big like kind of a
children's like playhouse or something
kind of little deal
it was a multi-storied playhouse with
little balconies on it
you know it looked like an apartment
building for guinea pigs and there's no
way
they look like little people in there
and there's no way that you would ever
eat one of those
but some people are rolling in and being
like oh that's the one yeah that's
amazing man
yeah we never had any of that i've had
owl i've had some wild meats people that
have
like uh my sister's family will grill up
anything that's dead
so we've had owl we've had like what
else did we have a roadkill type
what owl roadkill oh no they'll have
like yard chicken just chickens that
they've raised in their yards i'm trying
to think of what else that i've had that
was probably
you know kind of unique growing up snake
sometimes somebody i used to work on a
farm for a couple years and people would
kill a snake
and somebody sometimes if somebody had
enough time they would cook it at lunch
um he must be an alligator because
that's on all the menus down there yeah
i've eaten alligator frog was really
you know when i was young it was fun to
give a kid some frog you know
at the restaurants they used to have a
lot of uh these kind of
singing kind of they had like this kind
of black
group of gentlemen that were like a
quartet and they would sing and then at
the end of the thing they would give all
the kids a little bit of frog you know
it was just like uh something like fancy
kind of restaurant we would go to like
when my parents were having an
anniversary or something but um
but man that's wild though i don't know
i've never met anybody that knew how to
i knew how to hunt with a hawk i mean
that's pretty and do hawks have a
or with a falcon does a falcon have an
arch nemesis in in nature
well falcons get eaten a lot by
eagles and at night
there they get eaten by owls because
they can't see anything at night
and that's why you put a hood on them
because when once it gets dark they just
get calm because there's nothing they
can do about anything
wow their eyes are adapted for seeing
both microscopically and telescopically
during the daytime
and but they're almost incapable of
seeing anything at night
but a lot of the western falconers um
when they you know they on sage grouse
and they have to hunt early in the
morning because their birds will get
eaten by eagles when the bird goes down
on a sage grouse
the eagle will see that from miles away
and go down and eat both the grouse and
the hulk man
do you know 80 percent of hawks die
during their first year
they have it's hard for them to figure
out how to hunt
and um they uh
you know only the really smart and lucky
ones survive
a lot of them they have a lot of nemesis
it's mainly
owls and and eagles so you're growing up
so you guys
so take me back also to the pigeon thing
so you would take a pigeon you would let
it go
you would put it on a train yeah we put
it on the train and it was like a pigeon
club you were in
yes so everybody have a pigeon they put
it on the train it goes to somewhere
maybe down to the beach or somewhere
wherever it takes it
myrtle beach or something and then they
let it loose
right and then like maybe a hundred
miles uh the really good
pigeons would go two or three hundred
miles if you
you know if you had a 500 mile homer
that's what you would brag about
that's like having like one of those big
marbles that does like a steely marble
wow that's fascinating man so
so now whoever got theirs back first did
they kind of win the contest
i see that's amazing man
i can't even imagine that i can't even
because i think i would not have enough
trust in my heart that i would believe
that that bird was ever going to come
back
it must have lifted your spirits when it
got down you don't take my hundred mile
away
the first time you do it i would take
them to school in the morning
and let them go and go on the weekends
farther and farther away
and you know make sure that they come
back that's fascinating man
dude so what was i so when i picture
like you know
they didn't have any kennedys on our
street growing up and so i picture if i
ever thought of a kennedy you know
um i thought of like you know you guys
have like really nice dishes
like nice um you know cupboard
silver crabs you know everything like
was it like maypoles i picture like
people constantly like just dancing in
the yard
like was it what was a what was that
that's just what i picture i'm just
telling my house was chaos i had 11
brothers and sisters
and you know um i had a very very
you know i had a wonderful life
a lot of outdoor stuff my parents would
lock us out
in the morning and we weren't allowed to
come into the night and we spent a lot
of time particularly in the summer
i had you know i had my 11 brothers
there's 29 cousins we all lived together
and um you know there was there was a
lot of
mayhem a lot of laughter
and and uh and just outdoor
you know outdoors fishing skiing
um scuba diving
and when the older kids teach the
younger kids was that kind of how it
went yeah
that's amazing man yeah i can't even
imagine that
i mean it just seems like yeah because i
guess i just always thought about it is
and did it feel like you guys were like
so separate from the world of your
parents because they were living in like
a
more of like a political world well with
everything was
you know we we felt we were included in
everything i was you know
i the first time that i came to
california was for the
1960 convention and i saw my uncle get
inaugurated and then i
um flew back on the airplane with him
and sat next to him on the plane but my
father would you know my home was in
virginia but at that time
you could get to the justice department
in about um
eight or nine minutes of your driving
fast
and so my father would come home at
night he would talk about
integrating the university of alabama or
you know whatever the
issues of the day what was any you know
we were always included and then we
visited him the white
and at the justice department i
uh one day my uncle invited me
to spend the morning with him in the
white house in the oval office
we were you know we were part of all of
the
i sat behind a couch during the cuban
missile crisis
and you know listen to my our house
was kind of a sadly white house because
my father was the attorney general
and he was the president president's
chief advisor
we were a mile away from the cia
headquarters in langley and my
father at that time was um
you know was involved with the trying to
get the cia to behave
and so all of that you know there were
green berets at our house there were
cuban refugees
there was um you know
the entire milieu of that period was
yeah
damn dmv it sounds like you know i mean
it just has you know it's like
it just sounds like when i was like so
much going on
it was every friday when we were at the
cave
there would be three helicopters that
would land marine helicopters that would
land on our lawn every friday
and my uncle would get off president
kennedy
my father was the attorney general my
uncle sarge driver who is the director
of the peace corps my uncle
ted kennedy who was in the senate
already at that time um
and my uncle steve smith who was chief
of staff
and the white house would move to our
house for the weekend
and you know there was always
interesting people there
and um that we had in after 1962 my
uncle developed this very close
relationship
with with khrushchev
and the cia was baffled by khrushchev
because
they had never been able to get a spy
into the kremlin there was a mole in the
cia
and to this day they don't know who it
was
and every time they got a high-level spy
on the kremlin he would immediately be
killed
because the mall at langley was really
was so they really had no clue
what khrushchev was like or whether
it was a monolithic the kremlin was
monolithic and everybody was thinking
the same which was kind of the
assumption
and so he came to visit you guys he
never visited us now but he
exchanged um he exchanged letters with
my uncle secretly
he didn't want the kgb or the gru to
find out he was writing my uncle
and he um and my uncle was
was again they both figured out that
they were both at war with the
military and intelligence apparatus with
with which they were surrounded ah i see
what you're saying so it's like a
new chef and been a war hero
he had uh run the defense of stalingrad
under
stall and stalin and actually tried to
purge him at one point and the only
reason he didn't
was because khrushchev was running the
defense of um
of stalingrad and he couldn't reach him
because you know when hitler was trying
to attack song which is one of the worst
battles one of the most brutal battles
in human history
and one of the most expansive battles in
terms of human life and khrushchev had
no desire to
go to war his first meeting with my
uncle was a couple of
was about a month after my uncle took
office and they met at geneva and my
uncle went
into that meeting with very high hopes
that he could make peace and they could
begin
dismantling the nuclear arsenal on both
sides
khrushchev that met him very
pugnaciously and had been bombastic and
had given a
lecture about imperialism and said that
he was ready for war
and he was really kind of in his face
and my uncle went home from that meeting
very depressed
and then a year and a half later there
was a confrontation
when the soviets were building the wall
in berlin because they were hemorrhaging
people
everybody was trying to get out of east
germany and come on to the western side
which
the u.s controlled and khrushchev built
a wall there
and his joint chiefs of staff saw this
as an opportunity they wanted to go to
war with the russians
they believe that at that point in
history we had the nuclear advantage
the russians wish to soon catch up with
us so the president's chief of staff
wanted to go to war
well his joint chiefs did okay the
military
and the leaders of the cia
wanted to they wanted they saw the they
saw
war as inevitable and that the sooner
the better
because the u.s was at a big military
advantage in terms of its nuclear
arsenal at that time
and um and my uncle and khrushchev's
uh joint chiefs were basically in the
same position they were spoiling for a
war
my uncle who was also a veteran and had
you know
had a uh had seen his men die
um had three of his men on his bt boat
killed when it was run over by a
japanese destroyer and then you know he
had been lost at sea for
10 days hiding out on a little island
with the japanese
searching for him and he he mistrusted
the
the brass he had been lied to by alan
dulles
at the very beginning he knew dulles had
lied to him and fired alan dallas
and fired the top three guys the cia and
no longer trusted his military
and he realized that he was in the same
boat with
with khrushchev uh in 1962 khrushchev
built a wall
and one of jack's
generals lucious clay mounted bulldozer
plows on the front of
tanks and went to push down the wall and
the
russians met him on the other side at
checkpoint charlie
with their own squadron of jet tanks and
my uncle sent a secret message to
khrushchev at that point saying
you know please withdraw your tanks and
i promise
that when you do that we will watch
ours within 20 minutes and he said my
back is against the wall i have no place
to retreat
um and my uncle and father believe that
there would be
that there they lived for a lot of their
administration believing that the
military may
commit a coup against them that their
own military
yes at the u.s they couldn't trust the
cia because they
yeah they believe that yeah right
exactly their their military you know it
was
daniel ellsberg who was working in the
pentagon at that time said that
it was you know that at the the
atmosphere in the pentagon was one of
of rebellion that they believed that
the fact that my uncle had not gone into
cuba and bombed castro during the bay of
pigs which was
two months into his administration and
then he did not
bomb a khrushchev during the
uh during that confrontation
that was evidence that he was committing
treason against the united states so
they were really war happy at that time
huh
yes and your uncle came in and you're
and that's when your father was attorney
general and they were a little bit more
on the peaceful side of things huh
or the hopeful side of peace well they
didn't want to go to war
they in fact my uncle said when he was
asked by ben bradley who was one of his
best friends who was the editor of the
washington post what he wanted
on his as his epithet on his tombstone
he said he wanted he kept the peace
and he often said that the president's
principal job
was to keep the nation out of war who
was the better peacekeeper you think
your uncle or your father
when you look back even just like they
were working together at that time i
mean my uncle really
did not want to go to war and my father
ran against the vietnam war
and you know um yeah there's a lot of
famous pictures of him and stuff when he
was running
uh yeah oh
um you want to talk about
yeah we can talk about whatever uh
so you would if you do you
cause in your life this could be a time
i mean where you would
did you ever have presidential hopes
where you would be running for president
even at this time in your life
did i think that yeah i i'm
and not as a judgment or anything just i
was just thinking about that yesterday i
was thinking about
oh well when are people usually
presidents and it's kind of around your
age kind of
well i had an opportunity to go into
politics and i considered it many
times during my life probably most
directly during
when hillary um
when hillary was appointed secretary of
state
she was at that point the senator the
u.s senator from new york and occupied
the deceit that my father
occupied i had come close to running for
that seat in the previous election
decided not to and then hillary came in
and ran okay
um and you wish you had run or do you no
it wasn't right it wasn't the right time
for me
i had personal issues that i was dealing
with
and family i have you know i have uh six
kids and i
um i had a lot of per you know i need to
pay attention to what was going on there
and i like my life too as an
environmental advocate
so i ended up not doing that and then
when hillary
left two years later to go to the white
house
the governor of new york david patterson
called me
and it was his job to appoint somebody
to fill hersey
and he offered me that job so i
could have at that point chosen to be a
u.s senator without even
running for it i might add seed
but again for personal reasons i didn't
do it at that time
and you know i i kind of um live my life
like you do one day at a time and try to
make you know keep doing the next right
thing
and at that point it was clear to me
that the decision for me was to
stay at home with my family and continue
to do my environmental advocacy and
so i don't look back on that with any
regret or
you know i'm very much at peace with
where i am and were you going to have a
space in trump and
trump almost gave you a position or
whenever he became president wasn't
there talk of that and then it kind of
went away he just kind of went into the
end of the wind with it well what
happened was he con
in 20 over the christmas vacation
um 2016 he's elected right
and then obviously the election isn't in
november
so i was skiing
and with my kids in colorado over
christmas vacation
and i got a call from his chief of staff
saying the president
elect wants to meet crazy
and he wants to talk about vaccines so
uh you know i've been
an activist on trying to get safer
vaccines for a long time
of course i agreed to meet with him so i
went to immediately
after getting home i went to washington
where i went to new york
and met with him in trump tower and um
during
it was about a two-hour meeting had you
ever met with him before
i had sued him twice before a success
okay
and i had met him and you know the the
lawsuit um
was not something that had hurt our
relationship i stopped him from building
two golf courses in the new york city
watershed
about and those lawsuits were about two
or three years apart
so um and he knew me and he knew my
family he would
um when my sister ran for the for
governor of maryland he made a big
contribution to that he contributed to
my brother who was then
in congress and i had a cousin who was a
congressman from rhode island and he
made
contributions to that he was a big
democratic donor at that point
he called me he asked me to come in i
had
as i said about a two-hour meeting with
him at that meeting
people were coming in and out of that
meeting so um
so steve bannon was there um
ren's priebus you remember him uh
hope hill was there kellyanne conway
and uh and jared kushner
and both the president's sons at various
times were in that meeting
people and he but i had a lot of time
alone with president trump too
he said that he believed that
vaccines were making people sick
specifically
he had three women friends who were
mothers one who was in the building that
day
who had perfectly healthy kids who had
gotten
a you know their wellness visits
when they're around two years old and
the the children never were the same
after those visits they all
had been subsequently diagnosed with
autism and
he believed that it was linked to the
vaccines
and he you know because he had been open
about that
during the campaign hundreds of women
had as they did the same thing that
happened to me that got me into this
you know this career killing uh
um advocacy vaccine safety obviously
um you know people start coming up to
you and saying
you know this happened to me this
happened to my
son i had a perfectly healthy child and
who exceeded all his milestones and i
took him in at
16 months and he you know he was
speaking he was toilet trained he had
social interactions
and i took him in and he had a a shot
or a series of shots usually yeah could
be up to nine
yeah and now he's living in a 10-10 at
the circus right afternoon and they
at night they spike fever 103 they
have i mean the stories were eerily
all identical they had a seizure and
then over the next three months they
lose
all of their capacity to for social
interactions for eye contact they begin
oh yeah it's scary i mean a lot of that
stuff is super scary so but so you go
into that also
i go in there and say and he tells me
these stories and he says he wants to do
something about it and does it seem
serious when he's saying that like
yeah he was dead serious okay and he
asked
um you know whether i would run a
vaccine safety commission then he asked
what i would do and i said
listen i don't think you have to do a
big political lift
all i think you need to do is open up
the databases and allow independent
scientists in there to actually look at
the science because
the hmos have all the vaccine data down
to batch
for every child in america and they also
have the medical records so all you have
to do in fact you can do
now that is ai can do machine counting
and you can do cluster analysis
and you can figure out very very quickly
whether
all of these epidemics not just of you
know neurodevelopmental diseases like
all the atd
the adhd the speech like the the reds
and them though
um narcolepsy the asd and autism
oh yeah the allergic diseases food
allergies peanut
allergies oh it's crazy when you think
about asthma and all the autoimmune
adult asthma what even adult asthma
yeah well they but and they're all
listed by the way
on the vaccine inserts as vaccine side
effects because the only way that you
can sue you know they passed this law in
and made it illegal to sue a vaccine
company
for injury but you still can sue them if
they know of an injury that's caused by
their vaccine and they don't list it on
the side effects
400 injuries and they're falling down
the stairs everything
well all the autoimmune diseases but
they're covering all their bases that
way
yeah but they're not allowed to list it
unless there's significant evidence that
is actually being caused by the vaccine
fda fda is not allowed to allow them to
list
it unless fda believes it's being caused
by the vaccine but so then so the so the
vaccines they are approved by the fda
but is the fda a compromised group
though oh yeah the
it's actually you know people say it's
approved by fda but
actually the it's not approved the fda
robert stamp said
there's a panel within fda that's called
verback
v rbac um
that is uh and that
group is
staffed or populated by industry
insiders so they're not people who work
for fda and they're the ones who decide
on the licensing
and the problem is that vaccines are not
safety tested
right that other medications are and
there's an exemption
and it and it's an artifact of the
um of the the of cdc's legacy as the
public health service
cdc used to be called the public health
service and that was a quasi-military
agency that's why people at cdc have
military ranks like surge in general and
their
um and they wear uniforms and the
vaccine program was initially conceived
as a national security
defense against biological attacks on
our country
so the only reason that we had the cdc
was because we were thinking okay well
if some company
if some country poisons us or attacks us
we want to be able to
well that kind of program we had cdc was
out there
i mean cdc has other functions
but yeah the vaccine program the vaccine
program the russians
attacked us with an anthrax or some
other biological agent they wanted to be
able to formulate a vaccine very quickly
deploy it to 200 million americans
without regulatory impediments and so
they said
if we call it a medicine we're gonna
have to do double-blind placebo testing
and that takes five years because a lot
of
injuries from medications from all
medications
have um it takes time long diagnostic
horizons
so they found a loophole by naming it
something different by calling it
they're calling it biologics
i think and then and and influence
safety testing yes
and so that's why vaccines do not have
to be safety testing in fact
the covet vaccines that they're doing
right now have more safety testing than
any vaccine any history has ever had i
mean the one that pfizer approved
or the one that fires moving towards
approval that it just kind of released
some of the data on
um was tested on 42 000 people
and it was a i believe although we don't
know because we haven't seen the data
that it may have used a true placebo and
that's very unusual
and that's a go on sorry well the
problem
you know the stock market rebounded when
pfizer made these announcements yeah i
saw this physio and biot was the other
one biotech
that's its partner okay and
the problem with that vaccine is that
and by the way
if they come up with a vaccine that does
what people think vaccines ought to do
which is you take one shot you're
protected for life
there's very you know there's side
effects are
serious side effects are one in a
million
and um you know that i'd be the first in
line to take it
right i'm not any practicing you know
you're not an anti-vaccine i want to say
that too you
people say but you're a safe you're a
safe vaxxer
robust is we have independent regulatory
agencies right and that
vaccine that we're sure that the vaccine
is averting more problems than it's
causing right and that seems like pretty
reasonable i also don't think
at the government no matter what ought
to be able to mandate
that people take medications
particularly medications that have risks
and all vaccines at risk
if they didn't have risk it wouldn't
have given them immunity from liability
you know that's why so take to take me
through that when you say that if they
didn't have risks they wouldn't the
vaccine
here's what happened is they you know
when i was a kid i had three vaccines
my kids got today's kids get
shot doses of 16 vaccines so they give
them they load them up with the shots
and in that there's 72 vaccines there's
72 doses so you know if hepatitis b
you get five doses of that so but you
again
all together you're getting 72 doses
and the and the the change happened what
happened is they
added it sounds like a new jay-z album
didn't it nick 72 doses or something
and i i'll tell you a story real quick
before you go bobby i'll tell you before
you go on i'll tell you this story
so i grew up in a town where you know a
lot of they had a
primate testing facility in our town one
of the first ones in the country was
tulane university
and um which is one of the reasons too
i'm fascinated by a lot of the stuff
that
that you're into and that you speak out
on is because so when i was growing up
they had this facility it's one of the
first places that they tested the polio
vaccine
because it was um it was tulane
university they had a bunch of monkeys
um yeah is this some of the information
nick here
yeah that's the cutter well so they had
tested this
they had a woman in new orleans named dr
mary sherman
and she allegedly realized that some of
the vaccines that they were making
were actually giving people polio yeah
and giving people
uh and actually i think also causing
cervical cancer in women
i i've read this over the years and it's
just been a lot of lower energy there's
a woman at nih called bernice eddie
well she got murdered though dr mary
sherman oh yeah that's right that's
mary's monkey
yeah she got murdered in louisiana
associated with the
fk assassination yeah there was some
rumors of that and everything because
lee harvey oswald lived not far from
there like uh
because he went to school in our town
when i where i grew up yeah he went to
middle school there but um
but uh anyway so there was always this
lore that like um
just that in our area you know there was
a lot of lure about that kind of stuff
but they ended up giving that vaccine
out that's where i'm going they gave
they knew the vaccine or there was rumor
that the vaccine was failing
and they gave it out anyway yeah it was
and that's the cutter laboratories i
think that we're just looking at and
they
even in california i think it made 60
000 people
yeah he's paul offit he's saying 40
000 people got polio from it and 200
uh people got paralysis and 10 were
killed
and this is carter laboratory that was a
laboratory i guess that was
like working on the salk and saving
vaccines right
and uh but yeah so anyway that stuff was
always in my wheelhouse
growing up like oh and my mom was big
into that kind of stuff like are
vaccines safe what's going on here you
know
it was part of the lore in our area hey
can you guys
are you listening can you hear just want
to make sure that you are listening
because if you're not if you are
well you could probably use a pair of
premium wireless earbuds
especially now that you can get them at
less than half the price of the other
guys
i recommend wireless earbuds from raycon
raycon's newest model the everyday e25
earbuds are the best ones yet with six
hours of playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass who
don't want the bass
and a more compact design
a noise isolating fit man no noise for
you
just the sound you want to hear
raycon earbuds are stylish and discreet
no dangling wires
no dangling stems the company was
co-founded by ray j
snoop dogg mike tyson and they're all
obsessed with their products
give them a try raycon has a 45
day free return policy so you can make
sure
there's a pair of wireless earbuds for
you you have a christmas gift for
someone you need they like to hear stuff
boom done the everyday e25 earbuds from
raycon for a limited time get fifteen
percent off your order
at buy raycon dot com slash theo
that's b u y r a y c o n
dot com slash t h e o for a special 15
percent discount on raycon wireless
earbuds
make sure to check it out now while the
deal is running
great christmas gift for somebody great
gift for yourself
treat yourself b u y b-u-y-r-a-y-c-o-n
by raycon.com
theo you know a lot of people have a
hard time taking pills especially if
they're thinking about uh
sex you might be thinking about sex and
be like damn i can't take a pill right
now i'm trying to
you know think about sex but you can do
it all
and who's who who's here to help you
blue chew
if you like sex you're going to like
blue chew blue chew dot com
bluechew.com offers men a performance
enhancement
for the bedroom you can get the first
chewables
with the active ingredients sealed and
affordable
or ta ta tadao tata latful
had a lawful bluechew.com affiliated
physicians work
with you to find the dosage and active
ingredient that is best for you
they're not going to put you on some jaw
jacker you know then they're not going
to send you out there with a fifth leg
baby they're gonna take care of you
you want to look decent and feel decent
and have a decent wiener when you need
it
the chewables from bluetooth.com are
made in the usa none of these foreign
hitters
you and your partner will love it chew
it and do
it that's what they say it only takes a
few minutes
to connect with the bluechew.com
affiliated physician
here's a great deal do it now get
bluetooth for your stepdaddy
for christmas let him put that hammer
down on my ma you feel me
bluechew.com get your first order when
you use promo code theo
get your first order free that's right
visit bluechew.com
get your first order free when you use
promo code t-h-e-o
just pay five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e
c-h-e-w dot com promo code theo
um so why are why are so who kind of
controls
who why we get vaccines do
does the government control it or do
businesses control it
do we have any say now the industry
um which are four companies it's enough
if fizer and glaxo
um really control the whole process and
they control these panels that
the panel and fda ver pack that that
licenses the new vaccines and then it
goes over to cdc
and they mandate them and both of those
panels are completely controlled they're
staffed by industry they're controlled
by industry
and tony fauci is um you know
is the kind of the guy who orchestrates
the you know that
whole process but like i said we now
have the most aggressive vaccine
schedule in the in the country and
with the with the probiotic vaccine you
mean well no well
the problem with the covet vaccine i'll
tell you well here's the problem
is they they have all these vaccines and
they
recognize that it's going to be really
hard to get a vaccine that does what
people
say they would think it's going to do so
they have been reducing the standards to
make it so that they can
pass a vaccine no matter what and what
they think it's going to do is make it
so that they don't have to worry about
covet at all
right right is that what they're if you
get a shot you're protected you're good
and that you're not going to transmit it
okay
and that and particularly we want to
make sure that the
people who are vulnerable so people with
comorbidities
and fragile elderly that it's going to
keep them from dying
um but what they did is the the testing
protocols that they're using do not
require them to show any of those things
the testing process and i'll tell you
how it works they take
22 000 people and they give them the
pfizer vaccine
and they took 22 000 people and give
them a placebo
and then they wait and it's double blind
so
it's supposed to work is neither the
patients
the subjects test subject volunteers or
the
um researchers know who got what okay
and then you wait till 100 people get
sick from covid
that takes a while because you know you
have 40 000 people and
it's it's kind of hard nowadays
to get sick from covington you're not
going to have you know you're not going
to have the majority of those people
exposed so
after a hundred people get sick they
stop the study and look at it and then
they say
how many of those people got the vaccine
and how many got the placebo okay
and a 50 percent of the vaccine of 50
percent of the
placebo means there's zero efficacy and
the vaccine doesn't work well in this
case with pfizer everybody's excited
because 90 they
they stopped the study when 95 people
got sick
and apparently 85 of those people
were in the placebo group
which means the vaccine appears to be 90
effective here's the problem the
the way they measure whether you have
covid
is that you have one positive pcr test
you have one positive pcr test and you
have one symptom so that could be a
cough
it could be a fever it could be a chill
it could be a headache
and you have covet so what they're
testing the vaccine for
is not what we want to know does it
prevent you from dying
right does it prevent you from being
hospitalized understood
and you and we don't we will never know
from
because they have they have geared back
the studies
of it is to make them as peter toshi who
is the editor of the british medical
journal
he said this is a new york times
editorial
he said these studies were designed to
succeed so they you cannot fail
no matter how bad the vaccine is it's
going to pass
vaccine right everybody wants vaccines
so we can restart the economy
the big problem with this vaccine
there's two problems
one is it does not prevent transmission
that means i can get the vaccine
and then i get exposed to covid i still
give cover to you and everybody on the
airplane
you just don't experience it i don't
experience it but
it makes it even more dangerous because
normally you know we would know you have
it if i i'd stay home and i wouldn't
infect buddy but if i'm feeling like a
million bucks
and i'm still i become a super spreader
like you know typhoid mary
oh yeah you don't want that and yet
that's what
apparently this vaccine does it stops
you from knowing it but you continue to
transmit it the other problem is
that they're only testing them for a
month or two months
you're not going to see bad side effects
until maybe a year out a lot of these
um you know injuries that you get from
vaccines have very long
incubation periods autoimmune disease
like diabetes rheumatoid arthritis
graves disease crohn's disease
um ibs you won't see these
food allergies yeah it takes a long time
for those to incubate inside of the body
and what fizer's doing which is very
dishonest
is as soon as it finishes the study
it unblinds it so that everybody knows
you got the magazine you got the placebo
and then it takes all the people
in the placebo group and it gives them
the real vaccine
so now we completely are
unable to tell whether there's a long
term it's like covering your future
tracks kind of yeah
exactly and and it's a trick that
they've used in the vaccine injury
i industry that's the same thing they
did with the gardasil vaccine
but it makes it impossible for anybody
to ever know whether the reason they're
getting sick was because of that vaccine
or whether it was just bad luck
so why is it that we've become so like
why is it our government that's giving
so much power to these
um to these companies and less
less thoughtfulness to the safety of
humanity like
who's who yeah i mean the problem is the
entire sort of medical
cartel is now feeding
at the tit of big pharma yes oh the
the universities are getting all their
money from from
you know from sponsoring clinical trials
um the the regulatory agencies have
become
are are what you know are subject to
what we call regulatory capture
they've become sock puppets for the
industry that they're supposed to
regulate
and you know you see that everywhere i
mean i've been suing regulatory agencies
for 40 years epa
and you know and um and the state agency
that for example
famously in louisiana is utterly run by
the oil industry
is corrupt but
um the corruption is particularly acute
in hhs and the reason for that
is that that the agencies are really
part of the industry
so half of cdc's budget goes to buying
and selling vaccines
fda or or fda half of its budget comes
from the pharmaceutical companies
and with nih which is the other big
agency
they are collecting tens of millions or
hundreds of millions of dollars
on vaccine patents so they work on the
vaccine at the outset
they transfer the patent to gilead or
pfizer
the vaccine was completely developed by
tony fauci
he hands it to a private group they then
they put two billion dollars of federal
money into
allowing them to develop it and then
tony fauci's agency keeps half the
profits from the vaccine
oh it would be like you know i've sued
epa
many times for being a capture to agency
but you know what would it
what would it be like if the epa made
half of its profits
selling coal yeah it's the same thing
these agencies are not
independent agencies they're completely
captured and
you have and you know the all of the
other institutions of government that
that should stand between a greedy
corporation and a vulnerable child
have been compromised congressman
congress gets more money
lobbing money from the from the
pharmaceutical industry than any other
industry they give them
double what oil and gas because i'm
talking about lobbyists
there's more pharma lobbyists on capitol
hill than there are congressmen senators
and supreme court justices combined
agencies have been captured the press is
utterly captured and that's because
in 1997 we passed a law in this country
or fda
you know changed regulation to make it
legal for the first time for
on television and radio and newspapers
to advertise pharmaceutical products on
the air direct to consumer farms when
was that what year was that
i was 97 so there's only two countries
in the world that allow that everybody
agrees it's a terrible thing to do
oh and it's half of our commercials now
as well well roger hills who founded fox
told me that
that there are 22 commercials on his
average
evening news show and 17 of those are
pharmaceutical
oh yeah i'm just trying to get through
half a family guy and next thing you
know i have hiv by the end of the day so
you know what i'm saying it's just like
the fear it's in a lot of it's fear too
and they give you pictures of like oh
here's a happy family but you might have
this
looming in the distance you know yeah
you might have kevin
said that he wanted to do one of those
ads
where you know they you know they list
all these horrible things
from the side effects and the people are
walking around
happy and laughing and playing football
he said he just wants to do one of those
ads where people are actually
acting out the side effects
man he's so good they don't have snl is
not the same
it was so different when they had guys
like him carvey spade on there i feel
like the level of humor was just so
different um it's just gotten different
now on there
um so so you had so so you have this
meeting with trump just to get just kind
of going back to that
you have this meeting in the meeting
with trump and and and
you leave out of the meeting kind of
hopeful about it well i said to him what
do you want me to do and he said we want
you to announce
so a jared kushner escorted me
to the preschool scrum how tall is jared
kushner you think
he's uh he's about i think he's about my
size he's about six one okay
and i think you're like six one two i'm
about a little over six i'm reaching i'm
doing yoga too i actually did some this
morning
yeah well you start shrinking too on you
i mean
i told you the next 20 years of your
life are going to be a nightmare because
well you battle against it a lot i see
you at the gym all the time
yeah you used to yeah until it closed up
but i hear about you at the gym
sometimes when it opened back up briefly
the trainer that i have is like oh i saw
uh bobby kennedy in there the other day
yeah i was like yeah he's in there um
um so you left out of there was it hope
oh yeah so then i went down and
announced it
talked to the perez and then uh
a week later fizer made a million dollar
contribution
to trump's inaugural
and then trump comes in and we continue
to have
some meetings with algie and you know
that he
he had set up that we're part of this
process and we're rolling
to get this thing started does factory
seem legit when you talk to him he
seemed like somebody did he seemed like
uh oh he's very very charming but he's
not
he's listen ouchy i'm about to publish a
book on fouchy
yeah and he's um you know he's basically
he's been there for 50 years so he's
like j edgar hoover and the only way
that you last that agency for 50 years
is by carrying water for the
pharmaceutical industry and
under his watch he's supposed to prevent
autoimmune and allergic diseases
under his watch chronic disease has gone
from affecting 12 percent of the
american population to 54 percent we
take
more pharmaceutical drugs than anybody
in the world we do increase
prices so we it's we he's made this
country pharmaceutical nation yeah my
brother's allergic to
sesame seeds but you know exactly
and the way that you get allergies is
from the aluminum adjuvant
in the vaccine which is meant is put in
that vaccine
to initiate an allergic response and it
and so
if you have a sesame seed oil as an
excipient in the vaccine
or if you're if you're eating sesame
seeds when you have that aluminum
adjuvant in you
it can promote provoke an allergic
permanent allergy
and if you look you don't know anybody
who is my
age who has food allergies very very
hard to find i think it's one in
something like
1300 and today if you're born
after kill half a football team yeah
everybody after 1989 so any
anybody who was born after 89
i think it's one in 12 now autism went
from 1 in 10
000 in my generation to 1 in every 34
kids and it's the same with all these
chronic diseases that are all listed
as side effects so the proof seems to be
right there
well that's correlation which isn't
actually proof but
if you actually go into the scientific
literature
the proof is there but now is that
science so whenever you talk to trump
you said okay let's open up this this
database right this information because
you said like
yeah i said let's you know i said you
don't have to do
any heavy lift you don't have to go to
congress
you don't have to change regulations all
you have to do is open up the vaccine
safety data link which is the
medical records for the top nine
hmos and allow independent scientists to
go in there
and just open it up so they can start
publishing and did he do it
and no he didn't it's still locked you
know lockdown tony fauci
makes sure nobody can get in there and
you know even when congress ordered
these two scientists called david
michael geyer
ordered them to go in there and they
they let them
into the place they they gave them one
study room
they would not allow them near a copy
machine they allowed them
pencils and they had to write down data
and they they cranked the heat in the
room up to 105.
and they you know stole their hard
drives and they did right
they don't want anybody in that right
right
and writing sorry you've just written a
letter it's like having a stroke the
whole time it's like
i feel like it's [ __ ] insane have you
written something
i mean it's absolutely yeah i do i i
mean you might still write
but it's yeah it's getting uh
so anyway so anyway so big farmers
stepped in
and and trump appoints
pharma uh pfizer's lobbyist
to run fda um scott gottlieb
and eli lilly's lobby is alex azar to
run
hhs and as soon as they came in they
shut us down
and was that a big were you bummed about
that was i bumped
yeah i was very bummed i had a bit
bummed yeah
of course it was like within our grasp
you know
and do you think because i feel like a
lot of the thing with trump was that he
a lot of people felt like and feel like
that he was
trying to speak for like the just
everyday working guy do you feel like he
was like that
i don't know i don't know
i mean look he um he's also a [ __ ] i
mean he also is like
you know as also as this has this
mystique of being this businessman that
hides behind lawyers and you know like
um
just like every other businessman kind
of it seems like a lot of times
yeah you know what i i don't like
bullies and i didn't like that part of
his character i just
i i i don't care i'm non-partisan
if it's a democrat or if it's a
republican and they do something wrong
i'm going to call him on it and you know
i don't think
i don't think bullying people is uh
is a good um thing and i think you know
one of the
gifts that donald trump had was are
really
you know gifts of um
of demagoguery that he was able to
connect
to a lot of the kind of darker sides of
people to
bigotry and anger and i'm not you know
and i i i watch that happen that's not
imaginary and a lot of people think that
that's okay
do you think the media had a large part
in that i mean i'm not i think the media
was reprehensible
on both sides i think the coverage of
trump by
for example cnn um
was sickening because i you know i
saw trump do a lot of things that should
be criticized and
and you know that we should be horrified
by
but the media coverage was extremely
dishonest
and they weren't and the media coverage
of covet has been
you know absolutely dishonest and that
to me is what i
object you know what i object about the
for example the mandates the mass the
lockdowns et cetera
i read the science and if you go to
chd's website children's health defense
you can see the math studies that we've
been able to
to uh to accumulate and we take the ones
that say the matters work which are very
few and they're mainly cdc sponsored
and the many many many that say that
they don't work that they make you sick
that there's problems with it but
i don't take a position on that and see
if she doesn't take a position what i
the thing that offends me is that you're
not allowed to debate those things
why can't we why don't we see somebody
on cnn
who says i don't believe mass work and
here's why
and somebody else who says you know they
do work
and we should mandate them or have them
and let's hear the argument
let's hear the argument on the lockdowns
why are there no economists
on cnn who says yeah you may save 200
000 people who are going to die from
coven maybe
you're going to kill 400 000 from
disrupting the supply chains for
medication from deferred medical
treatment
from you know bankruptcies and here's
the cause
we can all see it normally i've sued
government agencies for 40 years
are not going through due process so a
government agency tries to give a permit
to an oil company to dump in the hudson
river
and i say no you can't do that
unless you go through notice and comment
rulemaking you have to post the rule
publicly so everybody can read it you
have to do an environmental impact or
regulatory impact statement
that tells the justification for the
rules so all the scientific
studies that you're relying on that
justify that rule
and you have to have a public hearing
you have to have a comment period where
the public can come out and comment on
it and say wait a minute
if you do that you're going to close
down my restaurant and every restaurant
my town and here's a different way to do
it where you can tweak the rule
get what you want without destroying all
these businesses
but there's a debate and there's back
and forth
and you have an administrative hearing
which is just like a trial where
they bring all of their experts in to
say
you know here's why we need this rule
and we the people who oppose it can
bring their own experts in
and then they do direct examination and
cross-examination and there's a
recommendation and the rule gets passed
none of that happened
we were just told you do what you're
told
mass work anybody who says they don't is
unpatriotic
is evil is trying to pass disease it's
inconsiderate and selfish
and they need to be shut up and shut
down
and not listen to and that's not
american it's not due process
it's not the way we work in this country
and what i think people are really
uncomfortable with i don't think you
know some of these people are selfish
but i think the vast majority of people
who are out there
with questions who are protesting are
protesting because they're very uneasy
about this kind of totalitarian
authoritarian control
where all of the you know the indicia of
democracy
and the guarantees of civil rights are
being abandoned it's being
well i mean it's it's it's funny bob you
strike me you know
it's it's like there's jetliners just
going up and down a
jet way and you're you remind me of like
a someone who's like but what about
due process you're like standing there
waving and that's what a lot of people
like i think
you know um you grow up you hear like
these are the rules of how we play
in this society and it's like there's no
one
yeah a lot of times it feels like no one
is following them anymore um so i think
when you get anybody
like trump who says who i think at least
like is
is a stern voice that's why i think one
of the reasons a lot of people voted for
trump
because at least he was like a stern
voice that was different
than the status quo i think a lot of
people
wanted i would have elected a [ __ ]
cookie i would have voted a chocolate
chip cookie in the office i was so
i'm so tired of politics in my life like
i just felt
i just felt like it started to feel like
and i'm just an everyday guy like
i don't know that much but it started to
feel like everything's been bought and
sold like
they're you know there's no one's
standing up for like just the
guy who goes to work and works hard it
doesn't mean anything
um you know there's no borders people
that are going to fight for
the military doesn't mean everything
started to feel like it didn't mean
anything you know
um i don't know i'm kind of rambling
here a little bit oh
i mean i i agree i agree with but it
started to feel like uh
i don't know and and it's not only that
the government
is no longer like working for us
and you know going through the process
of due process
and allowing debate but they're also
have this extraordinary capacity now to
sense of the press
my instagram has been shut down and it's
not because i said anything that was
untrue
it's because i said things that
challenge pharmaceutical products
criticize pharmaceutical products and
challenge government policies and say
would have said wait a minute
that policy does not make sense to me
for this reason yeah
they you can't not show me a single time
on my instagram that i
put something up there that wasn't true
yeah and yet it's been frozen
you know you're just asking people to
hey look let's can we look at this
like no there's no it it's definitely
like that especially like working in
hollywood and that sort of thing where
it's like if you even raise your hand
and say
but what about this like what about
these people like
why is uh racism always blamed on white
people if you even try to bring up a
conversation i'm not trying to get into
racism everything but
about anything but what about this like
what about mass
everybody just immediately just you
can't even
ask a question the me the minute you ask
a question
you are silenced it feels like
to feel kind of um one other thing about
mass is that
if you look at the history of
totalitarian regimes
they what they always do whether you
know it was on
franco or or mussolini or hitler or
stalin or
any you know or papadoc
they all do the same thing which is to
try to crush
culture and to crush any evidence of
self-expression so
um when hitler and stalin came in they
killed all the artists
who did not agree with a certain
paradigm with a paradigm that was
consistent with their ideology
it killed the poets that killed the
intellectuals they killed anybody
who was you know the the comedians
they have to get rid of them because
that is self-expression and what
is the ultimate vector for
self-expression
it's your facial expressions yeah and
they
you know a mask um putting on a mask
and not allowing human beings to
communicate
to each other and you know we have
hundreds of muscles in our face
and they were evolved to communicate in
subtle and beautiful ways to people with
very
you know um nuanced
changes and expressions definitely you
put that on people and that's
why you know with theocratic regimes the
most tyrannical regimes in the world
like
saudi arabia or women go to cover them
up for driving a car
they tell women you are chattels you are
property
you are commodities and we don't want
you to even show your facial expressions
so put on that burqa
and now i feel like you know we've all
been told to put on the burqa just wrap
it on be obedient
and what is the purpose of that in many
cases i think in the minds of some
people
it is a placeholder for the vaccine
hey you're going to keep that on because
the real money they put already 18
billion dollars into the vaccines
a the pentagon we just got a secret
contract from the pentagon
for model with moderna who is we
well my group children's health defense
okay and we were
we were able to get this they sent us i
heavily redacted the contracts between
modern
and nih and then a heavily redacted
pentagon contract but
even from that contract which you can
look at on my instagram you know
um says that
modern at the pentagon commits if
modernity gets emergency use
authorization which is completely in
tony falchi's hands
that the pentagon commits to giving nine
billion dollars to moderna
half of which goes to tony falchi's
agency
to buy 200 out 200 million
um uh or 500 million dollars at the
vaccine so
so that's two doses for every man woman
and child in this country and it's going
to the pentagon
which is the military which is scary
yeah so
you know there's so much money involved
here and the masks are really like a
placeholder they're like they're a way
of
it feels like oh it feels like
somebody's saying to us
you keep that freaking mask on your face
until you
get your vaccine and then we'll let you
take it off but until then
you keep it on and it's like
hostage-taking oh and it feels like you
keep your mouth shut it's hard to relate
to others with my mask on even like
it does i feel like i'm even if i'm in a
room with somebody feels like i'm not in
the room with them
there's a lot of uh there's a lot of
different things there and it's
interesting because you talk about
you know so many things where we don't
get proof we don't get
access to the proof of the studies but
with the mask i feel like we've
it's obvious that we've we get there's a
lot of proof that we get as individuals
like that
that it just doesn't feel very human you
know it doesn't feel very
uh it i don't feel like a human being
with that thing on yeah you know and
that's a cost
yeah if you head on over to theovon.com
right now you'll notice that our website
has been recently
revamped remodeled redone
and it's been done really well
there's never been a better time to step
up your web game
that's why i'm excited to tell you about
a game changing service by
modify.com that rivals any other option
on the market today modify provides
subscription based professional web
design
for the cost of your old cable bill look
my experience has been great we have a
great site
we have people available constantly to
help us adjust it
there was one price no setup fee no
setup fee
that's right modify literally just
finished our new site
it was effortless the turnaround was
swift it was
too good to be true modify's last
website plan is the best option out
there for any business that doesn't want
to do it themselves it includes
unlimited updates
unlimited support easy editing tools and
and future redesigns that's right
there's no big down payment
modifies last website is only 249 to
start
and 249 a month and they do 95
of the work for you that's right get the
relief of an evergreen website
with the convenience of having a
professional design team assign your
account to handle all your ongoing
website needs
you can check it out go to
modifymodiphy.com
theo to schedule your free demo today
that's m-o-d-i-p-h-y
dot com slash theo these guys don't eff
around baby gang you know that
and you know somebody said when i was in
europe um
you know and i didn't have a mask and i
spoke to this big crowd in berlin and
there was an nbc group there
that said to me you know why aren't you
wearing a mask aren't you scared
and i said i'm more scared of censorship
than i am of government
and that may sound insensitive because
people are dying of
but people died in the american
revolution too and they died in the
american revolution to preserve our
constitutional rights and our freedoms
and at some point we have to say you
know what kind of nation
are we are we are we the land of the
free in the home of the brave
or are we you know a land where
if somebody you know where somebody is
pointing to something and saying
be scared keep yourself in a constant
state of fear so that we can
you know so we can do some business
stuff
wait till we tell you what's next and
then you'll be ready wait till we get
the sponsorship money and then we'll
tell you exactly what you need now
why is that why would you say that to me
it sounds very normal
but i'm starting to get this weird
acclimation to
stuff like that sounding outrageous
right it and
i know that it doesn't in in my in my
immediacy but when i start factoring
into like
okay well if i say those things what are
people going to think what um
i think you're going to get a lot of
sort of hate
you know on this podcast i don't know oh
i don't think that we will
most audiences are pretty open to things
they they they can watch someone
and see that okay this is a person who
has a point of view this isn't
a vile person this isn't a bad creature
they might and also
not only might they agree with your
point of view but also they can just
hear it
i think most people can still hear
things pretty regularly i think a lot of
people
like you said it's just become a lot of
fear you know um
i'm just of a different ilk i guess
where it's like
i don't know just i don't know man i
feel like i can't say what i'm trying to
say right now but
everything they just make you feel so
crazy if you think anything different
and you can't share it on twitter
twitter is totally
you can't even ask a question on twitter
without
being well they have all you know they
have a whole infrastructure of trolls
and
you know response um
that is just you know it's all pharma
paid for and it's hateful and all of
that but you know there's also a lot of
people who just
you know and particularly in my party
which is the democratic party
at sea mass as uh as a symbol of moral
rectitude and
um you know they believe it and i my
you know my orientation is science i've
been
you know i've been litigating on science
for 30 years
for 40 years and and you know like i
strive
was part of the trial team on the
monsanto case my wife came to
to watch man oh monsanto's from crops
huh
yeah and round up you know round off oh
dude hell yeah dude we used to
uh yeah i got freaking a bunch of
fertilizer dumped on me one time and it
burned a lot of my skin
yeah well you need a good lawyer man i
should have had one there bro
it was crazy dude it was a different
time though oh we tried those the three
monster cases that you know ultimately
brought down the company
and my wife who you know cheryl hines
came to the trial and she was you know
we
she was there on a day when monsanto's
um harvard experts were on the stand
and they were so convincing and
persuasive that
you know that that roundup was
completely safe
and she said to me well you know why are
we even here these guys know what
they're talking about they're educated
they have graduals and they're
utterly convincing and then the next day
she heard our guys
and she was like well i was that guy
from ours was
totally full of crap oh you know the
idea that the idea that
we can trust an expert to tell us what's
good for us
every trial i've ever been involved with
there's an expert on both sides
and they're all both equally convincing
and that's why you need the debate
yeah that's why you know saying tony
fauci that's why people say
i want a second opinion yeah he's a
doctor
he hasn't treated patients for 50 years
he's a doctor but he doesn't know
anything about
economics he cannot tell you how many
people are dying of of
um of unemployment there are studies
from the 1980s there's a famous study in
1982 in the 1980s there was these huge
downsizing and layoffs that were
occurring in our country
and there was a whole cottage industry a
whole a school of economics that grew up
to see what happens to people when they
get unemployed
and there's one very famous study it's
it's cited hundreds of times
in the literature that said that for
every additional one point
in unemployment there's thirty seven
thousand americans die
yeah nine hundred nine thousand diet
heart attacks 900 from suicide
and so on and so on hypertension
diabetes
all these lose their healthcare all of
these mad things there's a cascade of
bad things happen
our population was about half so you
have to double that
and say for every point in unemployment
we're going to lose
maybe 60 000 dead and otherwise would
not have died
and are we start saving more lives
are we killing more people with the
quarantine than we are killing with
covin that's a great question
nobody has done that assessment and
that's the weird thing is people say
listen to the experts
but anthony fauci is not an expert
on deaths from unemployment and
you know and when when britain did this
study
written in five weeks in april and may
there were 30 000 excess deaths
in elderly facilities which they call
nursing homes
in britain but only ten thousand of them
had covered
20 000 of them died from isolation oh
yeah i'm not shocked
i mean i noticed even just in my own
like you know going a 12-step and going
to recovery and not being able to have
those meetings and not being able to
oh i mean the addiction rates are i
cannot even imagine bro
right i cannot even imagine how like and
you and i know people yeah
and died yeah you know during this or
people who couldn't go
to our meetings you know and it's a lot
of people's livelihood and that
and that's a lot of people and there's
no talk like there's just no talk about
the human effect of some of this it
feels like sometimes
it's just about this weird medical
effect
or medical fear which kind of it's not
shocking
then if big if if big pharma and that
money
is is so slowly seeped its arms all the
way and everything
that at the very pinnacle of discussion
the only thing people are concerned
about the media is concerned about
is the medical effects of it and no
longer the human effects of it
i mean why doesn't anderson cooper ever
not once had an economist on [ __ ] bro i
don't know bro
[Laughter]
you know i mean that's just my thought
bro but you know what i'm saying i'll
put side control on that dude in a
heartbeat but that's just me
you know um i don't know though i don't
know here's a question right here from a
young man
who's probably about to die of something
well i have a car accident at the same
time
no i'm just joking thank you for uh for
sending in the video we can't hear it
out here nick i don't think
uh i had a question in the meantime um
uh
so you said how the the pfizer
vaccination right now
doesn't uh you can still spread covid
yeah
with the camera so so do you see a world
where
this they push forward with this you
could still spread it but it supposedly
makes you healthy
but then we still have to keep the masks
on even because
what you said about the facial
expressions that was like terrifying but
it seems like
the way they're kind of marketing it
right now oh you can still spread it we
may still even
yeah i mean i it's going to be really
you know we really have to
be utterly under hypnosis
for them to be able to tell us to take
this vaccine
when the whole point of the vaccine is
the only three points
because we don't care if you get a fever
or a chill
nobody cares about that what we care is
do you die
right you have to get hospitalized
and does it tran do you transmit the
disease to others
right here's a vaccine that doesn't
prevent any of those things as far as we
know
how can they now mandate that people get
that
it's kind of it's a it's really a
complete
um disconnect it is a it's it's
it's a it's cognitive dissonance
where people will say um you know
somehow this is a life-saving
medication because it prevents you from
coughing
and it does nothing about anything to do
with this virus
that anybody cares about but then why
would everyone do why would
they agree to that then why would they
i you know listen they'll
what they'll do is in my view
is they'll mandate it for
activities so that you can't go to a
ball game
that you can if you're a nurse they'll
do they'll do like nurses doctors people
who work in nursing homes first who
lose their job firefighters first
responders
and then they'll do the university of
california the university of california
just mandated a flu shot
there is no flu this year and flu shots
we know
from the literature increase your chance
of getting covered the pentagon did a
study in january that where they gave
you know placebo group of soldiers and
they gave the
flu vaccine and the soldiers got the flu
vaccine with 36
more likely to get coveted a coronavirus
not
a virus 19 but a coronavirus but there
are many many many other studies and
people should go to children's health
defense website my website
there's a there's a you can look up
letter to sanjay gupta which is a letter
i wrote to sanjay gupta which
outlines all of these studies that show
that
if you get a flu shot you are much more
likely to get coronavirus or
some other upper respiratory viral
infection
it wrecks your immune system and yet the
university of california mandated we sue
them
we lost that lawsuit because the judge
said well you know
um i'm not gonna i'm not gonna arbitrate
medicine somebody's already made that
decision
uh that's the problem is that and then
they're gonna tell you
you can't go to a ball game you can't go
to a bar you can't go to a movie
unless you get the vaccine but back to
that berkeley back to the university of
california case does that
is that but does that shot do more good
than it does bad
the flu shot does much more listen
people should not listen to me and i
always tell people this
you need to look at the science but i
can tell you what the science says
and then you should check on this you
can go to my website to the children's
health defense website look at my letter
to sanjay gupta
and i go through because there's been
three major studies on
which are called medic reviews which
means there are there are hundreds and
hundreds of studies on the flu shot on
various aspects does it prevent
hospitalization and the elderly does it
cause injuries and in babies when it's
you know
maternal flu shots et cetera so there's
hundreds of questions
there's hundreds and hundreds of studies
and there are three meta reviews our
meta review
is one a group of scientists go out and
says we're going to look at every study
that's ever been done
and tell you what the state of the
science is
right now on these questions so the meta
reviews have been done
two of them by the cochrane
collaboration
which is the ultimate arbiter for
pharmaceuticals it's 30
000 scientists who don't take
pharmaceutical money and the top
scientists in the world
recognized by it the leader of him is a
guy called thomas jefferson he's a
founder and he's very very famous
british
british scientist he's not the president
he's a
he's a british scientist and then the
other was by the british medical journal
and here's what they said
you have to give a hundred flu shots to
prevent one case of the flu
there's no evidence at flu shots one
person you mean
to prevent one case oh you have to
you have to give a hundred shots to
prevent one case of the flu
you're only preventing a case there's no
evidence that the flu shot prevents
any hospitalizations or any deaths in
fact since they started giving the flu
shot to elderly people the death rate
has grown up dramatically
a flu shot is not preventing deaths in
the elderly
if you get a fluid shot you are you will
not get
you're less likely to get the flu shot
of that strain of flu
but you're five times more likely to get
a non-flu infection
and that you're six times more likely
to transmit the flu so the flu shot does
not prevent you from transmitting it so
that's what the flu shot
and we've had the flu shot for 90 years
so the cobot thing
almost sounds like it'd be just another
flu shot almost that's what it's and
that's what i've said from the beginning
we've had a flu shot for 90 years
and that's the best they can do and
covid
it's much more it's much more difficult
to develop a coronavirus vaccine
and one of the problems that's unique to
coronavirus vaccine in the past
is the coronavirus vaccines are known to
wreck your immune system
they've done and it's a it's a phenomena
that is known as pathogenic priming
um and what they found is they give the
coronavirus
vaccine to ferrets for example in 2014.
good eric's developed a very good
antibody response and ferrets you mean
the animals
yeah and the ferrets they use ferrets
because variants are the
are the closest analogy to human beings
when it comes to
upper respiratory viral infections yes
and so that's what they
they always use ferrets disgusting
sorry i know you love animals but they
pissed on me at my buddy [ __ ]
curtis's house and that [ __ ] will never
go away man
but he let him out also and he said yes
to you from that oh dude it was
they are just wow anyway go on i'm sorry
so
anyway they gave it to the ferris the
ferrets got it very good anybody
response but then when the ferrets were
exposed to the wild coronavirus
they all died i see you're saying so
it's pathogen priming it's like
it'll like uh it'll help you to that one
specific thing but then when something
else comes along
it makes you less likely to be able to
defend yourself exactly
wow here's a question right here from a
young man
hello mr kennedy it's great seeing you
top it up with uh theo here
um i know you're really concerned about
children's safety i'm just kind of
wondering what are the top
three to five um you know areas of
concern
you know chemicals etc uh influencing
uh raising kids right now all right
thanks bye
well you know and that's a good question
there's a we know that there's been a
dramatic
um explosion of chronic disease in our
children so
in 1946 of americans had chronic disease
by chronic disease i mean
autoimmune disease is one category
allergic diseases
um obesity also is in there and then
neurodevelopmental diseases
and in 1946 percent of americans had
chronic disease by
1986 12.8 had chronic diseases according
to hhs studies
but it doubled and you know people
then the vaccine schedule had gone from
three
during that period to 11.
and then in 2006 hhs studied the issue
again and found that 54 percent
of americans have chronic disease
american children
you know dramatically more than half our
kids rths
is what the health and human services
that is the
kind of the uber agency in which cdc
fda and nih are housed okay
oh and they did the study um
and the question is what is causing this
explosion in chronic disease we know
it's not genes
because genes do not cause epidemics
they don't cause sudden epidemics
genes can provide a vulnerability
but you need an environmental toxin and
there's a
scientist called phil landrigan
who looked at all of the possible
suspects
and he came up with i think about 11
and one of those is um you know is
past is glyphosate pesticides which
follow the
the timeline um neonicotinoid pesticides
which again
follow the same timeline um
pfoas which is a flame retardant that
became it's in children's pajamas and
it's in
you know it's in masks in fact beyond
uh that are made by 3m so we're
breathing that
you know which is carcinogen um
and then uh emfs which are
basically cell phones and and then
vaccines and those are the primary
culprits and it would be very
easy for the government there's a
there's a narrow view i mean one of the
other ones that's on that list is
ultrasound because ultrasound you know
followed the timeline
and it's ubiquitous it's in every
hospital and it's all over the world and
all these babies are getting it so
it has to be a suspect oh i understand
that for a baby if i'm a baby and i hear
something like that i'd be
i don't believe it but i don't know much
about it i
i believe that the you know the real
culprits are the
vaccines i think the pesticide i listen
our kids are walking are swimming around
in a toxic soup today so their
their immune systems are under constant
assault
and what happens is that a lot of those
substances
open up the blood-brain barrier so a lot
of the toxics that normally your body
could excrete
are ending up going into their brains
and you know
you're getting all of these
neurodevelopmental effects
and you know and it's probably you know
you also have fluoride and drinking
water
you have dental amalgams which are you
know mercury
and so there's all these different
toxins but i would say kind of the
the um that i'm most worried about the
ones which are
the emfs from cell phones and from the
towers 5g
i think it's going to be really a
catastrophe and we don't know the
long-term effects of that
no and and there are literally
tens of thousands of studies that show
that
it in including a 30 million dollar
nih study that was just released that
show that you know they cause cancer or
they cause
oh yeah the animals hate it cell damage
and
you know and they cause brain injuries
they change your eegs kids who put a
cell phone to their head for two minutes
their eegs do not um return to normal
for 12 hours
and it's all around us right now so 5g
is really i think a catastrophe
yeah we don't know the long-term effects
of these waves going through our body no
damns microwaves we're going to turn i'm
going to turn into a [ __ ] snail by
the way i don't
i don't mean to depress you no it's okay
look i knew it was coming here's the
thing i know every time i answer my
phone that it's coming i know when i
wake up in the morning after i do yoga
after i meditate once i start to reach
for that phone there's no denying that
there's a ping
which i now call it ironically that goes
off inside of my head and in my spirit
that tells me
it's not a good thing to do well you
know what there's people first of all
i never put the stuff on next to my head
um i always hold it put it on speaker
and hold it away
um but and i have one room in my house
that's
armored so there's no emfs in there and
i sleep in that room and i you know
there's people who now will do that
you have to make sure because the
predatory industry oh that's for the
elite right there
armored bedroom well it's you know they
painted with carbon
and the thing is we're you know my group
children's self defense is fighting a
lawsuit in front of fcc
so we have a woman who's an israeli
attorney she used to be she used to work
for the israeli defense
forces in their intelligence unit she
was doing
all of that she was completely
surrounded by cyber warfare
electronic equipment all day and she was
fine with it and then one day
it just leveled her and from then on any
time she gets even near her cell phone
she gets sick
she came into my house this is why i did
it okay she because
i got seven kids and she came to my
house
[ __ ] i think he had six kids in this
podcast you know i'm married general and
she has a kid
she has more no no you do yeah she does
a better kid beautiful kid
so um anyway
she came to my house and she said you
have and she's
so sensitive to it she can tell
different parts of the house in
different regions of each room where i
have
the other thing is i could check her
story
cause i gotta meet her she gotta give me
the meter
and then she said follow me around and i
will tell you
where it's hot where are you and she can
go to any part of my house and say
this is like killing me right here and
i'll turn on it
on the meter and it goes off the chart
she came into my bedroom
and it was just you know it was wild
dirty electricity everywhere and
particularly next
out of my bed and i said so at that
point i was like okay what is it going
to cause
let's do it one room
um where you know where there's and i go
in that room and i can sleep at night
yeah and i you know i go right to sleep
and
i have never been able to sleep in my
life i've kicked the sheets for hours
and look it's hard to sleep when there's
a lot to defend out there you know
it really is though when you have a lot
in your soul to defend what was that
question that came up from that young
lady nick
okay let's answer the one that came up
with that younger who he had the child
and he said what would you do
that first one you showed me when i
walked in if that's okay
um the guy who looked like he was almost
was he from salt lake
hey theo this is randy rally from salt
lake city utah
i just had a question for robert kennedy
i just wanted to know i've heard him say
that there are no
safe vaccines out there so if
he had a newborn right now
would he vaccinate that child would he
be selective about the vaccines that
he gives that child or would he just
forego any vaccines at all i appreciate
the input
i appreciate the uh information and
love your show man gang gang gang bro um
that's a good question so i you know i
don't give people advice on what to do
because i'm not a doctor
but i would tell you what i would do i
fully vaccinated all my kids
and i also took the flu vaccine every
year
you know and you know this thing i got
in my voice which is called spasmodic
dystonia
i was actually reading i'm doing some
litigation against the companies and
part of it i had to look at all the side
effects
and for the first time about a month ago
i was looking through you know when you
look at the side effects that they
publish on the manufacturer's insert of
the vaccine they're
you know they're some of them are pages
long and they'll have you know
60 or 70 injuries and one of the top
ones
of the flu vaccine was spasmodic
dystonia which is what i got
i was taking a flu vaccine every year at
that point and
for years doctors have said to me what
trauma did you do because you need a
trauma to trigger this i got this when i
was 42.
wow and so for the first time it
occurred to me that this might be a
vaccine injury my kids
are all healthy robust holy man boys are
pretty tall
yeah they're they're uh jesus i have one
that's uh
one could you barely call me better to
six foot five i see the one kid
and um uh but
you know they have a severe peanut
allergies and
others we have asthma we have um adhd we
have
all of the you know the stuff that is
associated with that
generation born after 1989 the vaccine
generation so
i here's what i would we'll tell you
there's
i would never i if i could go back i
would
um unvaccinate all my kids because i
think they did suffer injuries
um i would never give a kid a vaccine
that had
aluminum or mercury in it so some of the
flu vaccines of mercury sell about 13
um and then there's a lot of the
vaccines that have aluminum
and i would really stay away from those
the problem is that none of the vaccines
are safety tested so there's none of
them where you can say
that this vaccine is going to avert more
problems than it's causing
i would do your own research look at the
ingredients of the vaccine
and ask yourself if you want those
things in your child's body
and look at the side effects and ask
yourself do i want to take this risk
and remember this and the
according to hhs fewer than one percent
of vaccine injuries are reported
oh you have to multiply what you see on
that
list by a hundred because we don't know
that they're injuries from it
because people don't know like my i
never reported my kids
uh on food allergies and vaccine and now
i recognize that
of course that's what they are right and
people you know the doctors are
reluctant to report them because if you
let's say you get your shots the doctor
said that it's going to be good for your
your child and your child two days later
or a week later gets a seizure or get
sids
or something else and you go back and
say could it have been the vaccines
the doctor will say absolutely not
because he doesn't know
he there's no there's no course
in medical school on vaccine injury it's
not taught they're just taught the
vaccines are all good
they never hurt anybody and you know
they they're necessary
well will they be taught though down the
road because i mean or does
does big pharma influence like what's
taught at the school
big pharma owns the journals and it owns
the medical schools because the medical
schools
their funding is coming from those
pharmaceutical companies because
what the way it works there's
researchers who are
the teachers at that medical school
are a lot of them are running clinical
trials for the pharmaceutical companies
that's how they make their side income
right and the medical school so
pharmaceutical company will say pay that
doctor let's say twenty thousand dollars
a patient
you know for the the people that he's
experimenting on
for new medication and um
the medical school takes half of that
money
as a as a you know skims half of that
money off
plus if the if that product that that
doctor is working on
actually makes its market the medical
school then can collect royalties on it
the medical schools are making billions
of dollars
from these companies and if the medical
school does something that the company
doesn't like
the company stops giving it business
and so of course and so they you know
the companies if pharmaceutical
companies are can dictate
virtually every aspect of you know of
what happens at that medical school
including the curriculum
it's money man it's the same as with
entertainment industry it's like
you know if they don't like what you
have to say sometimes or what you're
thinking then they
they don't go your direction you know
it's like i don't know there's like any
contrary anything that's contrarian i
feel like uh
it seems suddenly becomes conspiracy
these days
um does that make any sense or not
that's uh you know i mean
you know it's the way you know some of
my faith there's a way to attack any
any any inconvenient truth by just
saying that it's a
a conspiracy theory yeah and but it's
like the number one thing people go to
now look at this conspiracy theorist you
know
like i have a i had a comedy special i
did a few years ago that came out on
netflix and they
um just because of my accent and stuff
and and i
like this uh the somebody wrote an
article and it was like
if trump hasn't found his favorite
comedian he'll love this guy like
it was right during the election like
around that time and it just like
[ __ ] broke marcus like i've worked so
hard like 12 years to get this comedy
put together
and it's a sarcasm it's all sarcasm and
then you get to this moment and then
somebody just labels you one way just
because they're
[ __ ] dumb and don't want to be you
don't want to think or you know
recognize it just i don't know that [ __ ]
just [ __ ] burns me sometimes man
how immediately somebody can see you oh
you know like
annie yeah but you're not used for
safety vats and every time i say i'm
not an anti-vaccine i mean i was
listening i've been
trying to get mercury out of fish well
my mom maybe 40 years and nobody calls
me any fish
you know i i want to get the poison out
of the vaccines i'm not any it's like i
want
i want to see bells and automobiles it
doesn't mean i'm against cars
right but that it's a way to marginalize
you
it's a way to vilify you it's a way to
to justify
censoring you by putting you in that
category he's anti-facts he's crazy
don't listen to him don't let him
none of these guys don't let me on tv
you know anderson cooper
um there's no way in the world they
would ever allow me
on network tv make your own channel what
you should
tell me how to do that oh i think i mean
i mean i feel like you could do it
easily i think well it's funny because
when i you were coming in two people
who i love my mom being one
she said theo this is wonderful his
group the children's vaccine health
defense has a great email newsletter
i uh read it all the time it's called
the defender yup called the defender he
has some libertarian views i'm so happy
to have him
that you get to have him and then i said
well make a video
she said i can't i'm working but i would
ask him the impetus behind the formation
of the children's health defense other
than his standing up for the underdog
is that yeah i mean you know the
children's health defense we do
all of the issues that i was talking
about we do fluoride
we do um pesticides um you know we did
roundup
and then we you know we we do vaccines
and any exposure to children well our
issue is why is acceptable
that 54 of our kids are sick
we should have six percent top that are
sick that's what the background rate is
and why are we all walking around saying
this is normal yeah you know why is it
when i was a kid that
there were no kids with autism they say
one in ten thousand
but i've never met anybody who's 66 with
full blown all god damn hell no dude
you don't see people yeah they called it
by us the tism when i was growing up
yeah well we didn't have it we didn't
know
nobody knew it nobody knew why even or
ever heard the word autism until 1988
that's when rain man came out
right oh yeah he had it but yeah but it
wasn't real
what it's not what they call full-blown
autism it's more asperger's syndrome
yeah he had asperger's that's a good
point right because
autism is non-verbal
non-toilet trained um head banging
stemming horrible cut aches and that's
half of the people who have it so it's a
million people
and you don't see you will never
see somebody my age 66 walking around
the mall a man with diapers on
and a football helmet and banging his
head nonverbal
stimming and engaging in these
stereotypical
behaviors they don't exist they're not
locked somewhere
because there's no place to put them
that's a good and by the way
i was raised on the spear tip
of the movement for rights and care for
people with
intellectual disabilities my aunt you
know drivers my godmothers
founded special olympics my cousin
founded best buddies
i worked in the special olympics when i
was still called camp driver like maria
shriver
yeah she's right maria's mom maria's my
cousin
oh wow you met arnold schwarzenegger
before
yeah he's my husband-in-law of course
yeah that's crazy bro
that's crazy i remember seeing true lies
remember that movie
pretty good um let me think of one more
question do we have any other good video
questions to come in nick has one
yeah uh so you talked about how like
tony fauci
he doesn't make it 50 years in the
industry without uh
like holding water for the companies who
are some like current politicians
senators or governors
that you see out there who like are
really speaking truth and that
are someone to listen to that aren't
being are there any
that you you feel like are somewhat well
you know there's only one guy
in congress at this point who
is who stood up and he's a republican
congressman from
florida named bill posey and he
is you know he is fantastic
and he understands he you know but he's
been
he's been completely isolated by his own
party by the republicans in congress
they won't let him near any committees
and there you know there's a little the
senior scientist for cdc
a guy called bill thompson dr bill
thompson who's at cdc today and he's
been there for 20 years
in 2014 he came forward and he said
we've been lying to the public about
autism we he he's the scientist who is
the lead author on virtually every study
on autism and he said
we've been destroying the evidence the
data when it shows that children are
getting autism from vaccines
and in fact on the key study which is
called uh which is a
study published in pediatrics in 2004
and it's called the de stefano study
he was one of the five co-authors and
the their boss frank to stephanie when
they found out that black boys
who got the mmr vaccine on time
had 360 greater chance of getting autism
than
and children who didn't get it on time
and the five or the four co-authors
were ordered by the stefano to bring all
the evidence on black boys
into a conference room at cdc and then
to destroy the evidence
in big garbage cans and this scientist
um
came forward he tried to commit suicide
and he came forward hired an attorney
and he said i want to be subpoenaed to
congress to talk about what's happening
in my agency
remember he's still at cdc this is not a
disgruntled employee
he's the guy who sticks to his story
he was transferred out of that division
the vaccine branch into another division
and but otherwise they leave him alone
and they gave him a 25 000
raise you know they don't want him to
leave because when he leaves he's going
to talk
and bill palsy for the last six years
had been trying to subpoena him in front
of the committee and i talked to
um uh to uh jason chaffetz who is the
head of the government oversight
committee a republican from utah he
promised
the subpoena thompson and then he
wouldn't do it
i talked to um trey gowdy who replaced
him he wouldn't do it i talked to daryl
isa who i think is a congressman from
this district
and daryl ice uh promised old earrings
and then quit i said to him after he
quit i said
i called him and i said why did she do
that and he said because
i got calls i'm the speaker of the house
and he ahead of our party is saying that
if i conducted those hearings not only
would i lose my chairmanship but i would
be
thrown off the committee and so
you know the pressure they're getting
from the not just the democratic party
which is terrible on this
issue but the republican party they've
all been bought off
oh and that's a sad thing was did was
there any was there ever a chance that
trump was like this
this alternate piece that could have
brought down the whole system
and you know when i first met i because
i wanted trump and bernie to have to be
on the same ticket that's what i wanted
because then i thought uh why do why do
you just get to pick your vice president
why don't you have to
why don't you that's what they used to
do it was a separate election was it
really
yeah yeah because then why don't you
have a different type of person as your
vice president then you have to argue
about everything you know
yeah it seemed easy to just pick some
guy
well that's not how we do it so
but doesn't the president just pick the
vice president he picks them
up well they they have to be nominated
by the party
oh i see okay
but anyway going back to that um yeah
what i think a lot of people
thought that trump was going to be okay
there's this huge cis this clock that's
running
and i'm going to throw this [ __ ]
wrench into it and watch it
crumble was that ever a possibility yeah
i think
it was a possibility for a short time
but i think
what i heard was that after
we um we left
the um that
there were people within the
administration including hope hill
kellyanne conway and i think um
one of their husbands is a
pharmaceutical lobbyist
and um and renz priebus who had just
told him you can't do it
and then they took the money from pfizer
and
you know we were alive for a while
through we were live from january
when he takes the oath office through
march
and everybody in the agencies was
terrified of us
we were going to the agencies and we
were questioning them and making
presentations yeah having them
boys with friends yes collins
and then at one point mid-march you know
the lobbyists came in azar and gottlieb
and all those guys came in
and we got a note from francis collins
just basically
you know it was like a big bird like you
know
we don't have to listen to you anymore
so stop talking to us
and now and then like the white house
went dark
[Music]
do you feel like with the with uh biden
uh that with the new um
president or well first of all do you
feel like the election was fair do you
feel like they will have any what do you
feel like the outcome will be from that
do you feel like well i think you know
listen they'll go through the judicial
process my feeling is that
um that the courts are gonna uphold the
election
um i don't think you know i don't have
any doubt about that
the in terms of biden's
you know biden has made a lot of
statements that are very disheartening
about
you know mandating masks you know really
coming down hard on the lockdown really
you know
it's become part of the weirdly of the
liberal ideology
of just you know getting rid of civil
rights
and you know religious exemptions so all
the rights the first amendment the
censorship they're supporting the
you know the religious independence
they're supporting the end of jury
trials which is
um you know we're abolished for vaccines
um
and and and public assemblies and right
to petition politicians and all of these
things that have been part of the
liberal tradition
in western democracy but particularly in
the united states the
the liberals the traditional liberals
um in my party are have just walked away
from them you know
the weirdest sir most surrealistic way
now is there any do i have any hopes for
biden
um biden has appointed to his
covid committee a number of hacks
who are just part of aochi's network
but he also brought in david kessler
who is the used to be the attorney
general i mean the surgeon general
and david kessler is the one
person that i think gives me hope
because he is an independent thinker
he's an enemy of pharma he
understands that you know that there's a
problem
with the vaccines and so i think you
know for those of
people in this audience who um
want to encourage that that you know
he's a guy that people should should
write letters to
and should you know should contact and
say
express all of us need to express hope
in kessler that a lot of people are
are hoping that he will break with the
orthodoxy that i think is taking us down
this dark road
in our country it's getting dark man
here's a beautiful young fella right
here who has something to ask you
what up theo what up mr kennedy that
feels so cool to say
uh matt from north carolina here just
sitting here at work
like an american shout out to theo for
that hitter
appreciate yeah nice merch man that's a
beautiful one so my question for robert
personally i'm a huge advocate and fan
of
jfk i'm sure he was probably the coolest
uncle ever
um but my question is a little bit
personal like
what are the last moments or memories or
maybe your favorite moments and memories
that you had
of uh uncle johnny um appreciate you
taking the time for my question
much respect gang gang you know i'm sure
you always get a question about your
uncle huh
um you know i listen i i have a lot
many many great memories of my uncle
i i mean i think probably one of my what
did y'all eat did y'all eat what
lamb chowder you really of course we
yeah we did eat a lot of clam chowder
that's bad
man that's nice you know boston beans
for clam chowder
um hot dogs you think hot dogs
hot dogs popular when you were a kid
yeah of course
hot dogs hamburgers um
i when i was i think eight or nine years
old i wrote a letter to my uncle that
i still have um
and asking him because i was worried
about the environment about pollution
and i wrote him a letter um saying that
i wanted to
talk to him about it and he he had me
come into the oval office
and i spent a morning with my brother
the night before i caught a salamat a
big spot at salamander they'd come out
you know in the spring to divorce you
know it's a.r right yeah
oh yeah i know what they are yeah like a
land snake
so um and i brought him one of those and
i went
my my home had just switched from well
water to
municipal water and are you upset about
that i was because the chlorine killed
the
salamander and but i was in denial about
about him being dead and i brought him
in a vase
and i and came to my uncle and he was
poking him with a pen i have these
pictures too and saying you know
i don't think he looks well and i was
saying
no he's just sleeping he's okay and then
he took me out and we released him in
the rose garden fountain
um but he uh he arranged ultimately for
me to meet with rachel carson who came
to our home
in ianna's board i mean in virginia at
hickory hill
and i had dinner at our house and um and
also with stewart udall who was his
secretary of the interior
and so that was pretty cool but you know
he came to our house he wrote
we rode every morning um horses my dad
would take us
riding every morning and my uncles
sometimes would come
um i went to the hearings when they were
when they had the mafia when they had
sam giancana
jimmy hoffa uh um all the big mafias
might had this before the white house
when he was still in the senate
and i went attended those hearings when
i was a little kid and
you know we looked at all these
gangsters and
we sat in the front row and um and then
you know
so our family was a very very close
family
and um and they landed with the
helicopters every weekend
he would after he landed he would go up
and he would kiss my grandpa
and they would talk my grandpa had had a
stroke by then and
he would talk to my grandpa and tell him
what happened that week then he would
come down
from the porch and he we would all pile
into a golf cart that was a souped-up
golf
golf cart with 20 kids on it
and he would give us a ride around the
compound at very fast
speeds and so yeah it was a typical
uncle behavior huh yeah
it was uh it was a really it was a
magical
um god it sounds like we used to ride
behind the mosquito truck and get that
free gas
to come off of it you don't want to
spray for mosquitoes
oh dude nose up bro we would just
literally be just biking until we
couldn't even take anymore you know
i mean i wouldn't say i didn't see a
mosquito we would have war
games behind them because it was you
know that fog that stayed on yeah had to
hug the ground
yeah it was good and uh we thought it
was good for us
yeah we sure did it was a different time
um battling the uh the environment on
the outside of us and on the inside of
us
uh bobby thanks for coming in today i
really appreciate it thanks for having
me yeah anything else nick any other
questions
um yeah thank you so much man appreciate
it good to see you man yeah you too
always a pleasure man you're always
welcome back now i'm just floating
on the breeze and i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
in my bones but it's gonna take
little time for me to set that parking
brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
mine
[Music]
now